♪ ♪ ♪
- Finie, la tour brune. La
Nouvelle Maison de Radio-Canada
se dévoile enfin à son public.
Par centaines,
ils déambulent dans l'atrium...
- Je peux passer
de la question 1 à 8...
- ... ils sont curieux de
comprendre l'envers du décor.
- Bien, on a écouté le débat
des chefs, alors voir le...
où ça s'est tourné,
c'était vraiment intéressant.
- Après la politique,
c'est le journalisme de guerre.
- La lourdeur, ellrdeur, ellrdet
vraiment de la plaque à
l'intérieur, la plaque de métal.
- L'animatrice et ancienne
correspondante Célau
explique l'équipement nécessaire
en terrain hostile.
D'étage en étage, le public
visite des régies, des studios
pour mieux comprendre le travail
des journalistes.
- C'est bien impressionnant.
Parfois, les équipes
sont vraiment petites, puis
ils font quasiment des mirac
avec qu'est-ce qu'ils ont.
- La visite est à guichets
fermés. C'est plus de
5000 personnes qui visiteront
la Nouve
d'ici dimanche après-midi.
Mais devant l'engouement,
Radio-Canada a ajouté
500 nouvelles places.
sez-vous
de cette visite?
- Écoutez, on a été agréablement
surpris, C'est vraiment bien,
c'est super bien fait.
- C'est - C'est - C'est - C'est,
c'est moderne et tout ça.
♪ (piano) ♪
- Plusieurs personnalités de
Radio-Canada sont présentes
pour accompagner les visiteurs.
DANIELLE PROULX, comédienne
- Je la découvre en même temps
que tout le monde.ès
le fun parce que les gens ont
beaucoup de questions à poser,
une belle curiosité.
GENEVIÈVE BROUILLETTE,
comédien
- On est fiers de notre culture
puis il faut se défendre contre
tellement des grosses machines
comme Netflix et tout ça que...
je sais pas, un lia,
ça fait comme : "Non, non, on
résiste, attention, on est là."
- Vous pouvez me suivre!
- Cette ouverture des portes
n'est qu pour Radio-
Canada. À partir du 8 octobre,
il sera possible de visiter
gratuitement la fin de semaine
sur réservation.
- (en choeur): Merci,
Radio-Canada!
- Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Montr